It’s been a dramatic night: you were in
a hotel at a crossroads; the tide was coming
in; someone threw a pencil at you; you were
in the back of a big car with your grandmother,
on the way to sit an exam; you had to climb
over a wall but kept being tickled by a giant
squirrel. Then you woke up. It felt immensely
important, but when you go downstairs and
try to tell your companions about the extraordinary
things that travelled through your sleeping
brain, the results are sobering. You keep
saying that it felt ‘exciting’, ‘so
weird’ and ‘absolutely amazing’, but
– strangely – your attempts to get others
to experience the particularities of your
night are met by some dispiritingly blank
stares. Half-way through the narration, someone
pipes up to say the cereal is running low.
Another person mentions it might rain later.
Then the doorbell rings. It’s a poignant
impasse, but not an untypical one either.
It’s tempting to think the problem has to
do with dreams themselves – because they
are so odd, unique and specific to us. But
the difficulty isn’t limited to dreams:
it’s a general problem of existence, which
can just as well strike when we try to explain
how our holiday was, what we feel about our
childhood or our ideas about how society should
be run. Much about our lives is like a very
intensely-felt dream we can’t quite get
others to listen to properly. The reason is
to a striking extent down to a collective
lack of preparation, an insufficient sense
that what we’re trying to do is really very
hard and therefore will require a high degree
of skill and practice. We naively assume that
enthusiasm and authenticity can be enough;
and that if we feel something to be important
or beautiful, it will inevitably and immediately
strike others as being so as well. This charming,
though ultimately lonely, egocentricity can
be best seen in children who are among the
worst story tellers, because they have a touchingly
weak hold on a very painful idea: that other
people are liable to be in different places
from us internally and are highly unlikely
to understand, feel and see as we do unless
we go to considerable lengths to extract,
arrange and systematically package up the
contents of our minds for them. These are
some of the rules for storytelling: – firstly,
we know what we mean far earlier than anyone
else can and so we must understand a story
at least five times as well when it is to
be shared in company as when it is merely
left to marinade in our own brains. – secondly,
keeping a story brief takes far more effort
than letting it expand. The philosopher Pascal
once touchingly apologised to a friend for
the length of a letter he had written him.
As he admitted: ‘I’m sorry I didn’t
have time to make it shorter.’ – thirdly,
we need to simplify. The downfall of almost
all anecdotes is an accumulation of incidental
detail untethered to the underlying logic
of the story. If one is explaining how it
felt to see one’s grandmother, it is irrelevant
(and a waste of someone else’s rather precious
life) to say what time one left the house
and what the weather happened to be like.
We need a view of the branches, not of every
leaf. – fourthly, factual events (dates,
times, actions) are always less interesting
(though far easier to remember) than feelings
– and yet it’s the feelings that invariably
contain the kernel of what can intrigue others.
It’s how we feel about what happened, not
merely what happened, that counts. Most of
what comes out of our mouths is more or less
unsocialised, in the sense of not quite fit
for the consumption of the world and a legacy
of environments that sentimentally set the
bar of successful communication far too low.
Those who grow up to speak clearly are those
especially alive to the risk and the tragedy
of being misunderstood. The contents of our
minds, and even of our dreams, are never really
too strange or boring for others to understand:
it’s just that our culture hasn’t yet
taken seriously enough the bracing challenges
of narrating the real substance of our complex
days and nights to other people.
We publish new thought provoking films every week.
Be sure to subscribe to our channel and take a look at more of what we have to offer at the link on your screen now.